Hey, this is, um, I guess it's sort of funny
even though it's not, I mean like I, I hate
that I was right about this, but it has happened
and I predicted it.
Are we going to half ago?
And it is happening exactly.
Looney Lindsey Graham or flimsy gram as some
in the audience suggested I refer to him has
again flip flopped and now supports Donald
Trump's absurd, erratic, haphazard pullout
from Syria back on October 10th.
I did a story, this was just under two weeks
ago about how Looney Lindsey had turned on
Donald Trump when it came to Syria.
Flimsy.
Lindsey tweeted, pray for our Kurdish allies
who have been shamelessly abandoned by the
Trump administration.
This move ensures the reemergence of ISIS
and I told you at the time, you've got to
be really careful with flimsy Lindsey.
He is a flip flopper.
He is a put my finger to the wind and see
what will get me some kind of attention type
of guy.
He's always been like this.
He will sometimes come to conclusions that
can sound logical or remotely sane or not
overtly partisan, but then the next day or
the next week he takes the exact opposite
position.
Now, as far as the Syria thing is concerned,
I said 10 days ago, let's be careful.
Lindsay seems to be breaking from the president
here, but he could well be setting himself
up to appear impartial to appear unbiased
when it comes to Donald Trump's impeachment,
which he opposes by the way and case in point
like clockwork.
Now, he is pleased to be supporting Donald
Trump's actions when it comes to Syria.
He spoke to Trump over the weekend and low
and behold, flimsy.
Lindsay came out of it saying, quote, I am
increasingly optimistic that we can have some
historic solutions in Syria that have alluded
us for years.
If we play our cards right, president Trump
is thinking outside the box.
The president appreciates what the Kurds have
done.
Certainly doesn't seem that way.
He wants to make sure ISIS does not come back.
I expect we will continue to partner with
the Kurds in Eastern Syria to make sure ISIS
does not re-emerge well.
Well, well what a change of heart for flimsy
Lindsay.
This is the Lindsey Graham routine.
If you think back to the John McCain days
when Lindsey Graham would sometimes come out
loudly and say, I stand with my good friend
John McCain and I am a distancing from or
separating from taking a different approach
from what the Republican, you know, talking
point is.
And then it would just change.
And then he would say, well, okay, no, but
I mean I stand with my party and these toxic
Democrats, blah, blah, blah.
This is Lindsey Graham's routine.
He can be reasonable one day to guide us to
call out his side when they are wrong.
Uh, but also to tell us when it is that they
are right and it will trick some people and
there are voters who eat it up.
There are media outlets that fall for it,
but then he'll just go back to the Brown nosing
and the normal stuff that we actually have
come to know Lindsey Graham for and I told
you about this last week and it is happening.
Exactly.
Someone emailed me saying, David, do you think
that it's possible that Lindsey Graham is
being blackmailed?
I don't know about that.
There's no evidence of that right now.
What we have evidence for is that this has
always been flimsy.
Lindsay, this is what flimsy Lindsay has done
to get attention.
He has always done it.
This is the same Lindsey Graham who said a
couple of years ago, Trump is a race baiting,
xenophobic religious bigot that the Republican
party is doomed if it ALEKS, Donald Trump
and then he's Trump's best friend and Trump
is doing a great job and he's more optimistic
than ever when it comes to what is going on
in Syria.
Despite having said 12 days ago that this
is an abandonment of the Kurds, which it is,
which it absolutely is.
He's a dangerous guy.
He's dangerous because he is so attention
seeking in a way that Donald Trump, Trump's
also attention seeking, but in a different
way than Lindsay Graham that a lot of people
get fooled into thinking.
Lindsey is a sort of post partisan, trustworthy
guy.
He's up for reelection in 2020.
Uh, unfortunately, no serious challenger right
now.
Sadly, Graham is polling.
Last I looked and there haven't been recent
polls because it seems so lopsided.
He was polling at about 70% last I looked
in his South Carolina Senate, reelection,
flimsy Lindsay doing exactly what I predicted,
exactly what he's been known to do for what
is it, decades at this point.
Make sure you are following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
Follow me while you're there at David dot
pack
right.
We will take a quick break and so much more
still to be discussed with you today.